hello everyone and welcome to a daily
reminder of just how strong Bobby
Fischer was uh first if you remember in
1970 he defeated everyone in the palm of
the America in Arizona tournament or
rather he finished three and a half
points ahead of everyone which qualified
him easily for the candidates matches of
1971 and then in the first candidates
match he defeated the Russian
Grandmaster Mark taimanov with a result
of 6-0 which is absolutely incredible
then he crushes bent Larson also with a
result of 6-0 and then he goes on to
former world champion tigran petrozian
and he crushes him with a result of six
and a half to two and a half winning
four games in a row in the end of the
match and then he qualifies for the 1972
match against the Boris paski and he
takes the title away from spassky with a
result of 12 and a half to eight and a
half so there we have it that's how
strong Bobby Fischer really was